father had a heart attack in the bathtub  and he drowned I didn't even know he  took baths she ruined a place I was just  looking for the restroom but hasn't  moved since she lived here he hasn't  paid the mortgage in six months it'll  all go up for auction the furniture the  house everything  laughs your friends not since I became a  homewrecker do you need a place to stay  this is the worst thing you could have  actually done roommates wasn't Lea dad's  mistress I'm married to your father and  I'm not his mistress yeah well not  anymore  where's your mom she's basically just  staring at the wall of our camper  [Music]  I'm a broke Widow without a single  marketable skill I live with my  husband's ex-wife and a special hobbyist  drinking with his teenage dropout  daughter  [Music]  [Applause]  you  [Music]  you